CUNNINGHAM YEAH LARA
HERE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
RAMOS RIVAS WICKS
VERY GOOD THANK YOU PLEASE
BE ADVISED THAT ON THE
RECORD AND SEE ESTIMATES
-- MATTER SIR FIFTIES CALLS ONE
NEVER CALLED ME HAVE CONSENT
AGENDA HOWEVER -- QUESTION
DANCE BEFORE FROM CONSENT ITEMS
TWO AND THREE FROM CONSENT
-- IS OUR MOTION REMAIN
THE CONSENT AGENDA
SO MOVED -- MOVED AND SECONDED
WILL BY THIS WEBSITE REMISSION
ROMMEL'S PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT COOLEY FINE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
CARILLO I FLORA FOR A PERSON
FOR HE SAID I CAN NINE
HUNDRED OF I'M INSURANCE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS
MATHIS I CELL PHONE PROBLEMS
HI WE'RE SORRY THE MOTION
PASSES OUR MOTION REMAINING
TWO ITEMS NUMBER TWO AND THREE
FOR QUEST WHERE TROUBLE SIX
TWO ONE EIGHT SB ONE REQUEST
FOR TROUBLE SIX TWO ONE EIGHT
FOURTEEN RESPECT AS BEING TO
TWENTY TO HELP IS OUR MOTION
ON THOSE TWO LINES
TO MOVE THEM YES HELLO MY
SECOND -- SECOND MORE BUYING
THIS CALL MORE ABOUT THIS
MESSAGE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HI
CUNNINGHAM DAHLE GLORIA SO
I FLORA LARA NOW GRAYSON
HI THAT I CAN MOTHER JONES
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MAIENSCHEIN
I TRIED I AM MATHIS NUMBER
RIGHT FROM US I RESULT
I
PASSED IN THIS RULES
PROCEDURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH